Wonder Woman kicks off our next chapter
in rebirth with an adventure that
promises some big reveals about the
secret nature of the Amazons we've got
new writer che Fontana here to tell us
about the course change setting for
Diana in issue 26 so in issue number 26
we're really building on the world and
mythology that Gregg Rekha and the team
of artists have been doing in the
previous rebirth issues so we're not
taking away anything that's been done
before we're just building up and we
find Wonder Woman and she's just come
back to the arlington from this overseas
battle that she's been working on and
she's been viewing all of this big
action fighting stuff as Wonder Woman
out on the front line and that's the
place that she's very comfortable and
everything's black and white and you can
really you know who the bad guys are and
who the good guys are but when she gets
back home she's kind of struggled with
finding you know who is she and what is
she doing in a peaceful time so it's
really we start with the relationship
really between Etta candy and Wonder
Woman which is just a lovely
relationship they really really care
about each other and something that
Martha and also has really brought to
life in the art is these quiet moments
between Wonder Woman and headed where
you can just see on their faces that you
know they got each other's backs no
matter what and she's done a lovely job
with that I think really highlighting
Wonder Woman's heart and really has
compassion for people and how she
relates to people is really the key to a
great Wonder Woman story and it's
actually been a lot of research lately
into a technology called CRISPR which is
all about gene editing so we will learn
that maybe some of wonder woman's genes
could be used to eradicate a lot of
genetic problems in the world so it says
something that Wonder Woman herself
didn't even know was possible and
something that the scientist in her
world or have been working on and the
scientist in the real world have really
been working on seeing how we could use
gene editing
at technology but it is very much a
moral gray area because you know she's
just such a big hearted superhero and
she loves people and she really wants to
help people so I think when you have
that and you see that till sacrifice
that she's willing to do for those
around her I think that's a great one
who own the story that's a look at the
future of Wonder Woman and here's a full
rundown of this weeks DC Poulos
[Music]
[Music]
that's the news for now but if you want
to catch up with Wonder Woman and what
you've been up there with the Justice
League make sure you check out Justice
League at the Reavers collection deluxe
edition book 1 starting tomorrow we'll
see you next nth